aujourd'hui on va parler d'ordinateur on
va parler de dell
les espèces 13 pouces sont plusieurs
promesses ils vous promettent un
meilleur écran soit du full hd soit de
la 4 car je vous promettre un design
compact bon à la regarder comme ça
effectivement on a plutôt l'impression
que ces compacts ils vous promettent une
autonomie pouvant aller jusqu'à 19
heures 19 heures et vous promettent
également les meilleures performances
avec un intel core i7 beaucoup drame
beaucoup de mémoire fait pas mal de
choses donc ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va regarder si
effectivement toutes ces promesses sont
vraies est-ce qu'elles sont tenues
est-ce qu'il faut acheter les dell xps
13 de cette année si oui lequel dans
quel conflit à quel prix voilà tout ça
on va faire un tour complet des expés ce
trail et à la fin je vous dirai si ça
vaut le coup oui ou non
[Musique]
mais vous commencez vous présenter ces
nouveaux ordi de dell qui sont arrivés
on a reçus de colis celui-là est celui
là celui là est absolument pas vous en
parler nous embargo je n'en dis pas plus
c'est une nouvelle bécane de l'asie dont
je vous ai déjà parlé à berlin ifa comme
ça on n'en a pas on ne met de côté pour
l'instant
aujourd'hui on va se recentrer sur dell
xps 13 là vous avez le modèle aluminium
gris qui est vraiment super beau et puis
surtout à l'intérieur vous avez une
vraie finition carbone vraiment
magnifique on va les tailles et sain et
ensuite vous avez le deuxième modèle qui
est en or rose qui est pareil aussi
assez incroyable très très beau hyper
compact qui est aussi une finition qui
est vraiment magnifique
détaillons tout de suite ses produits
expense 13 est vraiment un produit qui
est très très très faim en terme de
dimensions il fait 302 pas 100 99 mm par
16 mm d'épaisseur vraiment très très
faim et surtout assez léger il fait à
peine 1 kg 27 c'est vraiment ça qui est
intéressant donc là dessus d'elle nous
fait une promesse il fait d'abord un
ordinateur complètement compact on à le
reconnaître il est très compact pouvez
l'emmener partout
il est très joli bien fini et ça c'est
vraiment déjà un point extrêmement
positif en terme de connectique puisque
connaissant l'extérieur on a en tout
trois ports usb type c dont deux ports
thunderbolt roi que vous avez ici
l'autre port usb type c se situe juste
ici vous avez un lecteur de carte micro
sd un port jack est ici un petit bouton
pour voir votre niveau de batterie et
c'est tout parce que cet ordinateur se
rechargent effectivement en usb type c
vous avez donc un bloc de charges
secteur vous le recharger en usb type
c'est très très facilement et c'est
vraiment ça qui est extrêmement pratique
avec cette machine
je tiens néanmoins à rassurer tous les
possesseurs de ports usb vous avez un
dongle qui existe qui est juste là qui
vous permet de brancher de l'usb tic
s'est directement vers un port usb un
peu plus standards comme ça au moins
vous avez de quoi le rassurer
bon c'est pas hyper beau mais ça marche
c'est plus important lorsque vous
louerez le design est également très
très très bien soignée de la parte
d'elle vous avez des bordures qui sont
extrêmement fine il ya quasiment pas de
bord pour si vous avez toute une partie
en carbone qui est vraiment très sympa
un grand trackpad un clavier rétro
les global mans d'un point de vue
purement esthétique la copie est
vraiment réussie par dell les xps sont
extrêmement fins très beau hyper race
est hyper lookée le fait d'avoir le
carbone là c'est magnifique
que vous soyez sur le modèle aluminium
gris ou sur le modèle aux roses c'est
vraiment top
la couleur n'est pas la même à
l'intérieur il en faut pour tous les
goûts par contre que le toucher est
vraiment hyper hyper agréable et ça pour
moi c'est aussi un point qui est très
très très positif l'écran maintenant
vous avez un écran de 13 3 pouces c'est
un format 16 9ème d'un côté ou de
l'autre c'est exactement la même chose
exactement la même chose non pas
vraiment un point de détail près qu'il
fait vraiment la différence sur ce
modèle là vous avez un écran 4 k 3840
par 2160 pixels et là vous avez un écran
full hd 1920 par 1080 pixels mais c'est
pas la seule différence parce que sur
l'écran 4 cas vous êtes un écran qui est
complètement tactile
vous allez donc pouvoir naviguer très
facilement le tactile marche vraiment
super bien réagi très rapidement
c'est hyper hyper agréable alors l'autre
côté vous n'avez absolument pas d'écran
tactile
dans les deux cas vous avez une dali psc
du lcd en plus ce qui est vraiment bien
c'est que l'angle de vision est très
large pour remettre deux côtés on voit
extrêmement bien ça c'est top
il ya un vrai bon boulot qui est fait là
dessus et vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement qui de 60 hertz
alors après il ya un point de différence
qui est très important parce que là
effectivement on va se dire que avoir du
tactile c'est ce qui est le mieux c'est
pratique c'est beau en flic on fait ce
qu'on veut c'est que c'est vraiment bien
oui mais attention parce que vous avez
une dalle 4k vous aviez tactile ça va
consommer beaucoup plus est ça en terme
d'autonomie
c'est un petit peu changé la donne aller
plus loin son autonomie je vais vous
parler de la puissance de la performance
parce que là dessus sont les deux objets
sur les deux modèles hong hanh intel
core i7 cadencé jusqu'à 1,8 gigahertz et
4 giga hertz en mode turbo
c'est la huitième génération d'intel
core i7 et franchement ça marche
extrêmement bien en bouillie de sel sont
couplés à 16 giga de ram ddr3 en terme
d'affichage trouve que les deux écrans
fonctionne très très bien que vous soyez
sur la captation du full hd dans tous
les cas ça marche extrêmement bien
échauffée c'est aussi un point très
positif de ces xps 13
cette année là on est sur deux images
quatre cas là vous avez un vrai écran 4
cas sur la gauche à la droite c'est pas
un écran 4 cas on voit par contre
certain qu'il ait une différence je sais
pas si vous allez vous en rendre compte
comme ça directement l'onu mais il ya
une vraie différence en termes de
couleurs les bleus et six sur l'écran
quatre cas sont beaucoup plus prononcée
on va avoir des verts qui sont beaucoup
plus vif beaucoup plus de contraste
beaucoup plus de détails au niveau de la
couleur c'est de me rapprocher comme ça
pour vous montrer donc là on est sur
l'écran xp tresser le 4k là on passe sur
l'écran full hd
il ya une vraie différence regarder le
bleu le bleu est beaucoup moins intense
là là dessus le bleu en droite est
beaucoup plus intense
la promesse au niveau de l'écran et là
franchement ça marche extrêmement bien
vous serez sur quatre cas où sur le full
hd maintenant puisqu'on parle multimédia
dans les tirs au niveau du son parce
qu'avoir un bel écran c'est bien mais
avoir un son pourri ça le fait pas et là
justement ce qui est plutôt pas mal là
dessus c'est que vous avez des hauts
parleurs stéréo premier haut parleurs
qui va se situer ici sur la partie
gauche de l'appareil est forcément a
contrario vous avez le deuxième qui
situé sur la partie droite de l'appareil
la frustration enfin les haut parleurs
le font bien là et bien là
mercredi on aurélia j'ai l'impression
que le son vient de là donc il ya une
vraie spécialisation qui rendu par la
position des haut-parleurs ça marche
bien c'est vraiment cool
du point de vue audio le spectre est là
il ya suffisamment de puissance pas la
peine en avoir plus pour éviter de se
rendre sourd en plus de ça les aigus
sont assez claires je trouve que c'est
assez bien fait les graves sont présents
sont assez jolis alors on est sur des
petits haut parleurs on va pas
développer non plus beaucoup de bases
beaucoup de grave
avoir une puissance de l'img mais sur un
ordinateur de cette taille en 13 pouces
ça fait extrêmement bien à faire bisquer
on parle de joey puisque une prise
casque dessus on va se faire un petit
test de l'audio directement avec la
prise jack pour voir si au final
derrière la qualité est là aussi
ou bien alors pas du tout voyons voir
[Applaudissements]
sans voix franchement du bois
le son est vraiment beau les graves sont
vraiment super jolie un son qui est très
équilibré je gueule parce que forcément
j'ai le casque sur les oreilles ça me
rend complètement sourd mais je trouve
que vraiment mais vraiment le son est
super bien est vraiment supérieure au
niveau du casque qu'au niveau des haut
parleurs forcément mais c'est vraiment
super donc l'expérience multimédia audio
et réussi et remplit aussi bravo d'elle
s'il ya bien un truc que je dois
raccrocher à cet ordinateur c'est sa
webcam parce que je trouve que
l'emplacement est vraiment pas idéal
il se situe en bas de l'écran c'est une
caméra en 720p voit pas trop lui en
demander par contre je trouve que c'est
pas vraiment pratique parce que lorsque
vous filmez avec la voix de gamme
vous vous voyez la qualité déjà est pas
terrible en tout six sites je suis
vraiment aux conditions de luminosité
qui est bien chez des éclairages de
chaque côté néanmoins je me vois à
l'écran j'ai du pixel de partout ça me
fait un bruit pas possible et le
problème c'est que ça film dense où ce
qui fait que on voit en gros metro né
voilà ça c'est pas extraordinaire
on voit le double menton et je trouve
qu'il ya un effort qui aurait pu être
fait de la part de dell là dessus c'est
un petit peu le point négatif alors
après est ce que je comprends
parfaitement
c'est que comme vous avez un bord qui
est extrêmement fin tout autour si vous
allez poser une webcam en haut vous
allez forcément avoir un bord qui plus
est pêcheur dessus c'est moins joli
c'est moins bien mais bon voilà c'est un
peu le point négatif est en train de
tourner en super là dessus c'est le
clavier parce que je trouve qu'il est
vraiment hyper pratique et on arrive à
taper très très facilement
il ya un vrai retour de touche qui est
vraiment super c'est super agréable
lorsque vous allez taper des messages
lorsque vous allez écrire des mots
d'amour clavier qui est complètement
rétro éclairé et ça aussi c'est très
pratique et l'autonomie dans tout ça
parce que d'elle nous vend sur son site
une bécane qui peut tourner jusqu'à 19
points 5 heures d'autonomie s'emparer
beaucoup ça paraît franchement beaucoup
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas poussé
jusqu'à 19,5 heures d'autonomie j'ai pas
réussi à voir et 19 points 5 heures
d'autonomie
ça dépend effectivement des conditions
de test c'est toujours un peu compliqué
d'aller vous dire très exactement
combien d'heures vous allez pouvoir
l'utiliser parce que ça dépend des
logiciels que vous allez utiliser ça
dépend si son roman s'ils vont me taper
un petit peu dans le processeur ou passe
à l'époque pas mal de choses par contre
une bonne dizaine d'heures sans aucun
problème alors une dizaine d'heures à
vous dire 19 heures lire plutôt dit
voire un peu plus 10 11 on se rapproche
de ça c'est en tout cas ce que j'ai pu
en marquer sur cette desquels sauf que
vraiment la batterie est impressionnante
parce que sur l'utilisation un petit peu
standard sur de la bureautique / d email
je parle pas de montage vidéo sous
première une chose qui sont un peu plus
grand mais vraiment sont des choses un
peu plus classique visionnage des vidéos
sur du multimédia une bonne dizaine
d'heures 10 sont 12 heures vous les avez
vous êtes tranquille et ça pour moi en
tout cas c'est pareil la promesse est
tenue par dell dont bon plutôt couleurs
promesse tenue
on n'est pas à 19h je dis pas qu'ils ont
pas eu de 19 ça dépend comment sont
réalisés leur test en tout cas plus de
dix ans je les ai ça sans aucun problème
donc je trouve ça aussi plutôt cool on
va maintenant parler de la config ça
c'est un point qui est super intéressant
parce qu'il existe plusieurs points de
conflit justement vallée détaillé
ensemble parce que lorsque vous voulez
acheter une bécane comme ça et la
première chose à se poser comme question
ce sont les usages qu'est ce que vous
allez faire avec un xps 13
alors bien évidemment j'imagine des
email naviguer de la bureautique
regardez du multimédia des vidéos ça
c'est package un petit peu standard
jusque là tout va bien il n'y a pas
particulièrement beaucoup de questions à
poser derrière par contre qu'est ce que
vous allez avoir comme usage dans les
années à venir parce qu'une machine
comme ça vous n'allez pas l'acheter pour
un an deux ans trois ans vous allez
l'acheter pour minimum 5 ans donc il
faut réussir à se projeter un petit peu
sur les usages que vous allez avoir dans
les années à venir alors si vous pensez
que vous allez rester un petit peu sur
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui vous
prenez une config de base vous êtes
tranquilles par contre et c'est à mon
avis là dessus qu'il faut vraiment se
poser la bonne question dès le départ
avant de partir c'est qu'est-ce que vous
allez avoir besoin comme stockage dans
les années à venir
est ce que vous allez plus tard vous
dire tiens je vais faire de la vidéo
tiens j'ai faire du montage vidéo
par contre si vous voulez faire du
montage vidéo je vous conseille très
clairement de réfléchir montage vidéo
1080p full hd ou alors quatre cas si
vous voulez monter la capca derrière il
vous faudra un proche suffisamment
puissant il vous faudra de la ram donc
toutes ces questions il faut vous les
posez savoir ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui ce que vous allez faire plus
tard pour pas vous retrouver qu'une
machine obsolètes ou du moins une
machine limité ça c'est le plus
important parce qu'en réalité lorsque
vous allez pouvoir passer votre commande
vous allez avoir plusieurs possibilités
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau du stockage
256 giga 512 1 tera de terrain forcément
ce que vous allez monte plus ça va être
cher ensuite en terme de puissance vous
avez soit un intel core i5 swan intel
core i7 huitième génération
ensuite en termes de ram
8 gigas de ram 16 giga de ram et vous
pouvez même choisir votre système
d'exploitation soins windows dix
familles soit un ubuntu linux 18 points
0,4 la config bien moins cher c'est à
dire avec 8 gigas de ram 256 giga de
stockage celle du ssd je précise c'est
dur ssd est un intel core i5 ça vous
coûtera 1399 euros
si par contre vous allez sur la config
la plus puissante c'est à dire 16 giga
de ram 2 tera de stockage un intel core
i7 2599 euros entre les deux les pouvoir
trouver un petit peu votre plaisir moi
j'ai une bécane alors celle ci c'est
celle qui a un écran full hd 1920 par
1080 kg à 16 giga de ram 512 de stockage
en intel core i7 et qui coûte 1699 euros
si par contre je veux passer sur l'eau
des cales qui est là et qui a un écran 4
k et un écran tactile
sinon les specs c'est les mêmes 16 giga
de ram 512 il ya de stockage ssd intel
core i7
là par contre je suis à 1899 euros
c'est à dire que j'ai 200 euros d'écart
qui séparent ces deux machines 200 euros
d'écart pour avoir trois comme réelle
différence pour avoir un écran 4 k
tactile alors la question se pose aussi
dans quelques années est ce que la 4k va
se démocratiser
est ce que vous allez avoir besoin d'un
écran quelqu'un aujourd'hui tout de
suite à l'instant t
je suis patient par contre si je me
projette dont trois en quatre ans avoir
un écran 4/4 et mettre tout de suite 200
euros de plus en écran tactile en plus
ça peut avoir un réel sens donc poussé
vraiment cette question il vous verrez
on sait sur quelle machine partir point
final de ces xps 13 de 2018 bah écoutez
franchement je vous le dis je suis
vraiment agréablement surpris j'ai pu
découvrir ya pas très longtemps une
soirée à paris organisé par dell je les
trouve vraiment bien j'ai trouvé très
compact pour moi la promesse faite par
dell là-dessus d'avoir des ordis contact
elle est là très clairement très léger
très pratique très bien quels étaient
les faire tomber
je me fais engueuler ce que j'adore là
dessus vraiment c'est le fait d'avoir un
écran 13.3 pouces avec des tout petits
bords trouve ça vraiment vraiment
vraiment génial de la puissance de la
performance c'est vraiment un ordinateur
extrêmement polyvalent facile à emmener
partout et je trouve qu'en termes de
prix en plus il est extrêmement bien
placé vous allez trouver des pc beaucoup
moins cher mais avec cette configuration
derrière
dieu c'est avec une puissance je les
trouve vraiment bien et je ne peux que
vous voulez recommandée est elle une
place toute particulière dans mon coeur
et je lève je les aime beaucoup
merci dites nous ce que vous en pensez
qu est ce que vous pensez de ces espèces
13 es ce que vous avez des ordinateurs
de dell est ce que vous pourriez y aller
et je vous invite bien évidemment à
rester connectés parce qu'on va
continuer à parler d'ordinateur vous
l'avez vu il ya un laptop qui nous
attendent un cerf juste en bas donc on
va le tester d'ici quelques jours on
continuera également à parler d'elle
parce qu'ils ont des produits qui sont
vraiment très sympa on n'a pas mis et
pas très longtemps dans le casque de
réalité virtuelle de dell on va parler
d'ordinateur on va parler aussi
d'ordinateurs de gaming
donc restez connectés abonnez vous soyez
ça je vous embrasse tous marqué tous vos
commentaires 1 portez vous bien et à
très bientôt
[Musique]